this video is brought to you by
squarespace
in a corner of spacex's headquarters in
hawthorne california
you won't find rocket engineers or even
adults for that matter
for a number of years elon musk ran a
school out of his rocket factory to
educate his five children not including
boy number six
baby x they had been enrolled at a
private school for gifted kids in la
but musk wasn't satisfied with their
education as he once told the chinese
television network
the regular schools just they weren't
doing the things that i thought should
be done musk has been critical of the
american education system
pointing out teachers don't explain why
kids are taught a subject
they're taught a mathematical formula
without explaining why that formula
is important as an analogy he says
simply listing the tools you need to
take an engine apart
isn't the same as trying to disassemble
the engine yourself
and by doing so learn the relevance of
the tools as you go
when he's not happy with how things are
done the entrepreneur tends to do
something about it whether it's creating
rockets
cars computer chips or his own school he
named it ad
astra which is latin for to the stars i
actually
hired a teacher from the school they
were at who also agreed with me that
there was a better way to do it
that teacher is josh dawn who i spoke
with over skype
was it a tough decision for you to leave
the private school where you were
teaching at to go
on this new venture no of course not
right
i mean if anything you know elon asked
me to think about it
and i responded you know hours after we
originally spoke like in the middle of
the night because
it was so clearly a great opportunity at
astra was far from a typical school with
no classes in language
music sports or even grade levels
students were grouped based on their
ability where they took part in complex
team games to test their critical
thinking skills
in one simulation teams competed at
various art auctions to try to assemble
the best collections to display
at exhibitions around the world similar
to what these students are doing
i like this shrine game okay yeah you do
that one it's a lot for adults to juggle
let alone the eight to fourteen year
olds at adastra
musk reimagined how school could be
taught based on first principles
reasoning
a fancy way of saying how could you
rethink how something is done
in order to make it better a strategy
applied to tesla's manufacturing of
batteries
it used to be very expensive to build
batteries for electric cars
you could say that's just the way it is
and there's no way to bring the price
down
first principles thinking would say it's
possible to make cheaper batteries
by breaking it down to the basics
figuring out what the batteries are made
of
and how those materials could be
cleverly combined to form a battery cell
in education first principles mean
figuring out how students can get the
best learning experience possible
to bring about the best future for them
and for the world
i can't believe that it's sitting at a
desk listening to a teacher tell you how
to you know just stop ankle side
theorems in geometry class
and astra grew from nine kids in the
first week of 2014
to 50 six years later a mix of children
of spacex employees as well as high
achievers from the area
sometimes they ventured off campus a
converted garage at the former house of
gene wilder once served as a chemistry
lab
this unorthodox approach to education
doesn't come cheap
tuition was around thirty thousand
dollars a year with some receiving
financial aid
when ad astra closed in june 2020 musk
donated funds to kickstart an online
school called astranova headed by josh
dawn although the spacex ceo isn't
personally involved
he has his fingerprints all over the new
school a former spacex engineer teaches
rocketry there
and even the application is related to
one of musk's passions
interested students have to submit a
response to this environmental problem
how would you answer there's a large
lake near a small town
a corporation dumps harmful chemicals
into the water
scientists studying the lake say it'll
die in 10 years if the pollution
continues
an individual the puppet master is
concerned new regulations will impact
profits so they decide to pay a small
group of scientists to publish bogus
research claiming the lake has never
been healthier
the media reports on the new study
politicians have the power to stop the
pollution but decide not to since there
appears to be disagreement over the
health of the lake
plus the company employs so many people
in town its closure would devastate the
economy
voters who listen to the media
politicians and scientists
are confused over what the truth
actually is they re-elect the
politicians
the corporation continues dumping
harmful chemicals into the lake
and the lake dies 10 years later so who
is to blame
there's no right or wrong answer but the
school is interested in how the children
reason through ethical dilemmas
it's not about preparing the 100 or so
admitted students for an ivy league
education
in fact musk went on the record to say
degrees don't matter when tesla's
artificial intelligence team
looks to hire putting it this way don't
care if you even graduated high school
not to mention many smart people dropped
out of college like steve jobs and bill
gates
musk has said he simply wants evidence
of exceptional
ability which he hopes can be fostered
at a young age
and spacex of course is an exercise in
possibility the concepts are available
to kids around the world
online through a separate venture called
synthesis as people spend more time
online
the need for a quality website is more
important than ever whether you'd like
to display your work
start a business or a blog it's a way of
representing your brand
and now you can try it out for free i've
used squarespace for years to show off
my portfolio as a journalist
well before they became my sponsor what
drew me to squarespace is how easy it is
to create and edit my own site
it doesn't require any experience in
website building whatsoever
there are also many great templates to
choose from you can receive a
complimentary trial by visiting
squarespace.com
newsthink the link is in my description
and when you're ready to launch use my
discount code
newsthink to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website
or domain thanks so much for watching
for newsthink i'm cindy palm